c'est au début avril que clément maltais
manifestent les premiers symptômes de la
maladie
un test de dépistage à domicile le
déclare positif à la coved 19 mai malgré
ses 101 ans
pas question pour lui d'aller à
l'hôpital j'accueille temps et on
voulait mourir lance jeunes sinon mon
père sorties repas de la maison c'est ce
qu'a demandé dans son testament
j'ai dit mon père ni repas l'hôpital
krim maltais est alors malade mais son
état demeure stable
ce sont donc ces filles qui se relaient
pour lui prodiguer des soins à son
domicile de rivière reçu au cours des
jours et des semaines qui suivent
[Musique]
pendant cette période plusieurs membres
de sa famille élargie lui démontre aussi
leur appui le 3 mai un défilé en son
honneur est organisée dans sa maison le
tout en respectant les règles de
distanciation physique on a fait le tour
de la maison et sas véhicules au total y
avait des vélos il y avait des quatre où
y'avait d'une moto il y avait déjà été à
ce nombre de camions c'était vraiment
drôle et jean van hamme et dupang car
derrière des décorations qui on a fait
le tour et lui la main et rouillée
toujours à siantou donne sur la cour
d'eau qui a pu nous voir tout ce fric sa
chaise roulante 50% la guérison la
semaine dernière clément maltais passer
un second test de dépistage qui s'avère
négatif un grand soulagement pour son
entourage
l'acavite 19 veulent avoir marqué qu on
vous paye astana il est très fatigué et
il mange beaucoup plus il vaut beaucoup
mieux il y aurait eu beaucoup plus de
mobilité
il l'a vaincue elle a eu le vécu
l'oeil aguerri pays va aller mieux de
plus en plus ici marc antoine majou
radio canada sept-îles